clac avons publié chez laffont un livre
qui s'appelle t à l'automne que j'ai lu
j'ai beaucoup aimé parce que je trouve
qu'ils soient rapidement extraordinaire
alors vous êtes originaire d'italie
d'une famille c'est ces bourgeois
couvent oui j'étais encore en débat mal
gré à gré
alors quand vous étiez tout d'abord j'ai
gagné ce qui fait du bien de paepe lé
pape a appelé les rares et c'est à dire
pions séance et quand vous étiez petit
j'étais très ami avec les fils de buts
souligné
j'étais comment les fils de messieurs
les hausses étaient des bons garçons
tous les deux on était dans ma classe
tient au lycée et on s'amusait bien
la villa torlonia la maison de son père
on faisait des fêtes on allait à cheval
quelquefois et on sait bien qu'on en
sait rien du superbe rencontre il ya
cent ans ont des intérêts trois scènes
mondiales hors canton à vip est en train
jeunes et les noirs évasion
c'est pas pour moi c'est partout pareil
les seins avant d'accord il était gentil
au oui cette année
alors un jour et c'est là que de vie
bascule complètement
vous rencontrez un général en facilite
pas général à l'époque c'était un
officier de tchang kaï-chek il vient en
italie et qui s'appelle monsieur tam
il fait ses études en italie c'était
s'étale chinois que des études en italie
étaient envoyés par le gouvernement
chinois là il apprend seul mérite
militaire avital voilà et alors vous le
rencontrez votre vie bascule vous tombez
complètement amoureuse de lui
oui vous vous sentez que c'est votre
c'est votre amour quoi tout de suite n'a
pas d'oeil a pas de discussion c'est le
coup de foudre à torfou
alors c'est qu'ils prennent un sacré de
nous battre monsieur table parce que le
jour de votre luigi n'ose vous partez en
voiture qui vous amène dans un hôtel et
il nous fait boire du thé à l'opium
ça vous a pas surpris ça mais je l'aimé
tellement léger de ces jeunes que je
voulais faire tout ce que sur le terrain
peut être avant maintenant oui j'aurais
bien aimé vous rencontrez vous avez quel
âge à l'époque où vous viviez dit elle
huit ans
mais vos copines c'était pas comme vous
quand même bien que vous luttez comme ça
c'est exceptionnel quand même envie
pendant ce temps là il y avait des
femmes y avait des jeunes filles te
plaît pour moi mais bon c'est pas comme
s'ils avaient envie d'exotisme à oui
mais ça n'est pas le temps ce n'est pas
le cas vous partez en chine
je vais arriver la base du dépouillement
et que vous faites des enfants d'abord
j'ai fait beaucoup d'enfants
beaucoup d'enfants j'aimerais avec les
chinois je fais mon marché noir et 7,7
et vous découvrez que finalement vous en
dehors du coton et cultive l'opium ça
nous change pas beaucoup mais c'est un
truc est très étonnant dans votre livre
c'est que finalement tout ça vous arrive
mais bon vous voyez ça et vicieux
d'enfants vous n'avez pas vraiment de
jugement moral ou de jugement
l'éducation des bonnes soeurs mais je
n'avais pas tellement marqué non sa
veine en particulier est l opium à la
gtb louis la manipule sa mère un jour de
votre windows que vous avez pris une
telle qu elle se dit pas que c'était
d'opium on connaissait pas le pire mais
c'est vrai que maintenant wayne on ne
sait pas du tout faits peuvent tout à
fait une chose des faits mauriange pas
c'est une grosse licence vous arrivez la
bonne fête des enfants est lui parti
suite à la guerre
ils vous laissent alors là vous avez
une chose cachée étonnante d'ailleurs
c'est qu'un jour vous êtes endormi en
fait pas vraiment dormi vous pleuré un
peu de retard je triche je te veux te
marier pas là et il ya la servante qui
s'approche de nous là bas qui s'approche
de vous et qui commencent à vous faire
des calibres et un peu partout et se
termine quand vous êtes aperçu après que
la mère vous savez au oui je pensais
j'ai pas ce qui désoriente om ça parce
que j'en ai ma vie n'est pas là et la
femme n'a besoin estime-t-il d'amour
d'affection et est chose c'est une chose
même vision le dic est alors une autre
parce qu'elle ça au lieu de deux hommes
oui ça vous a plu
oui vous allez recommencer avait
commencé peu après ça tourne mal toute
cette histoire parce que bon vous le
suivez offrande d'habiter dans une
petite maison avec lui
maisons en bois puis je sais pas ce qui
se passe un jour vous apercevez que qui
vous prend pas avec une infirmière à ce
moment là vous faites un truc sous serre
que vous allez à shanghai tepa midi à
l'époque elle c'est extraordinaire il ya
dans votre fille d'une très belle
description de shanghai qui est partagé
à l'époque entre les différents pays
d'europe avec délégation avec les
quartiers tout ça
c'était une ville fantastique on peut
même pas la comparer à la new york
d'aujourd'hui n'est ce pas c'était
traître quelque chose et partenaires ou
des gens aient de l'argent des gens qui
débarquent enfin la bagarre mais quand
même
je vais rester là parce que la seule
ville que je voudrais terminer en
prendre mais les installer à l'hôtel
d'abord dans un dans un bel hôtel à
l'impérial qui ensuite dans un hôtel un
peu moins
un peu moins cher et alors il ya une
amie à vous qui s'appelle même si c'est
ça non oui vraiment qui vous dit voilà
on va ouvrir un restaurant laloux et
tout un étage et vous ouvrez un
restaurant et vous organisés comme ça
didier vous fait rencontrer des gens oui
elle est fait déjà l'effet des jardins
le gouvernement sino-japonais dans les
temps et faisait des dîners organisés de
dîner un peu des ambassades déjà foule
dans des directions
c'est une dimension qui est intéressant
dans vos clips c'est justement la guerre
la deuxième guerre mondiale vue de
lorient c'est à dire on voit comme ça
effectivement les japonais qui ont
envahi la pratiquement tout l'extrême
orient à commencer par là par la chine
que les japonais étaient sûrs qu'il
allaient cagnac et les allemands si les
amants ci est ainsi aux italiens sur mer
et port de montréal il a mal fait de
même et je pense que
les japon déjà donné mon avis tu dois te
donner des airs d information parce que
tout laissait on peut le savoir
d'autres fonctions mais alors un sort à
la guerre du salar si votre petit matin
harry c'est à dire que là vous commencez
à il ya un truc quand même qu'il faut
dire c'est que il vous arrive souvent
dans ce restaurant de finir la nuit avec
des clients quand même oui parce que
c'était des gens que je fais un prêt à
subir dénicher des informations est
alors j'étais obligé vous avez les
informations on attend mieux quand on
est marié comment dire oui c'est ça mais
est ce que vous regrettez aujourd'hui de
remplacer toutes ses nuits avec tous ces
hommes que vous connaissiez pas toujours
ça c'est un peu dur quand même comme
époque l'époque et maintenant alors pas
maintenant les officiers la nuit avec
des japonais des allemands des français
et dans ce temps là
l'heure est
et c'est un sacrifice je n'avais pas
moyen de faire d'autre alors après la
fin de l'ère il ya des bombes atomiques
ils ont besoin au japon donc tout
s'arrête et là vous avez quand même des
problèmes ce qu'on appelait en france la
libération dix ans j'avais été condamné
en tant d'années que j'étais en prison
j'étais impuissant et après je passais
la fourrer le tribunal militaire 1 bat
apprécié lier après c'est vrai j'étais
condamné à mort châtiment de la mort met
en prison
voyez quand même en prison de trouver un
joli joli japonais oui je vais pas
donner un petit bassin qu'on est près du
même âge à malte j'ai fait l'amour avec
mon mari je vais notre foi et bien et
c'est bien de tekken je pense une
français sont tous faux et atteinte
trafic et de l'os comment la faire venir
j'ai eu un destin extraordinaire
c'est étonnant toute cette histoire d'un
calage moi alors je sais mais ça si vous
êtes là c'est tout à fait le même
système
alors avant tout je dois vous dire et je
suis pas de cette année je suis un
extraterrestre comme on dit hassan et en
français extraits alors ton mec
s'intéresse comme féret ce que je peux
dire que j'ai 73 ans de chansons
présentes oui c'est ça mais quand je
viens de l'autre hémisphère
laisser duper une bz
merci en quatre lettres très bien les
corrections de ne rien rater de 1h10
tube abonnez vous mettez un pouce bleus